I'm so humbled thank you so much  Pennsylvania's Democratic Lieutenant  Governor John fetterman overcame any  doubts about his stroke recovery with a  narrow victory over television Dr mehmed  Oz this Senate raised one of the  tightest and most watched this campaign  has always been about fighting for  everyone who's ever been got knocked  down that ever got back up  the Keystone State's Democratic attorney  general Josh Shapiro nabbed the  governor's race handily defeating  trump-backed Republican and 2020  election denier Doug mastriano who  refused to concede we're gonna have  faith and have patience we're going to  wait till every vote counts right